[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend in ein bilder
eines krieges können dokumentieren was
geschehen ist sie können auf rütteln
können hilfe bringen sympathie
hervorrufen oder verachtung exakt
deshalb sind sie im krieg immer auch
eine waffe das gilt umso mehr je
grausamer diese bilder sind je mehr sie
eine grenze überschreiten die selbst im
krieg gelten sollte und eben weil sie
auch eine waffe sind müssen sie über
jeden zweifel erhaben sein gerade weil
eine seite umgehend versuchen wird sie
an zu zweifeln
aus dem ort butscher an örtliche von
kiew gibt es bilder die die welt
entsetzen sie zeigen straßen in denen
viele tote liegen überall
hier ist was wir über die situation dort
wissen
mehr als vier wochen war butter in
russischer hand mitte märz gab es
bereits die meldung von 67 getöteten
zivilisten aus dem ort und den hinweis
auf ein massengrab auf dem gelände der
stadtkirche wie dieses etwas verwackelte
satellitenfoto hier zeigt zwei wochen
später am 30 märz meldet ist die
russische regierung hätten ihre truppen
die stadt verlassen doch die gefechte
gingen wohl weiter meldeten ukrainische
medien und internationale beobachter
und der graben voller leichen ist
mittlerweile über 14 meter lang
erst am freitagnachmittag am ersten
april bestätigt der bürgermeister von
butscher dass die stadt wieder in
ukrainischer hand sei das erste video
aus butter taucht auf und es folgt das
internationale entsetzen und viele
weitere furchtbare bilder getöteter
zivilisten und soldaten auf butchers
straßen
heute war katrin eigendorf für uns in
butter hier ist ihr bericht
in der max-eyth-straße in butter sieht
es aus als seien die russischen soldaten
gerade erst vertrieben wurden die
leichen die hier lagen haben die ukraine
geborgen es sind bilder die nur schwer
erträglich sind das innenministerium hat
journalistinnen aus aller welt
eingeladen um das zu dokumentieren was
der russische außenminister sergej
lawrow falls eine inszenierung
bezeichnet präsident see lenski ist an
diesem morgen persönlich nach butter
gekommen es ist ihm anzumerken wie nah
es hingeht wenn er schildert wie hier
frauen vor den augen ihrer kinder
vergewaltigt und ganze familien
hingerichtet wurden das land müsse
kämpfen aber gleichzeitig verhandlungen
führen
ich bin überzeugt dass wir auf dem
territorium der ukraine frieden
erreichen die ukraine kann nicht im
krieg leben denn wir sind in europa im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
wir fahren ins bei ausgedienten verkehrs
bussen durch checkpoints vorbei an
ausgebrannten zivilfahrzeugen eine
gefährliche fahrt durch ein gebiet aus
dem die russische armee zwar vertrieben
wurde aber unsere begleiter rechnen mit
neuen angriffen im dorf macht tischen
führen und die ukraine an eine stelle im
wald in der vier tote liegen darunter
auch kinder
dort drüben in dem loch liegt meine
familie ich weiß nicht warum sie getötet
wurden sie waren friedliebende gute
menschen
[Musik]
wenig später bergen freiwillige die
toten in plastiktüten die buckel dieser
abschaum hat eine ganze familie
gefoltert geprügelt und ermordet sie
werden dafür zur verantwortung gezogen
werden wir finden alle die diese
schreckliche tat begangen haben
hunderte von toten für die kaum zeit für
eine würdige beerdigung blieb auch das
sind bilder aus butter massengräber
improvisierte grabstellen
tanja hat ihren mann im garten bestattet
sie bittet um frieden für irland
ich bitte sie ich flehe sie an tun sie
etwas ich spreche zu ihnen als eine
ukrainische frau eine mutter von zwei
kindern und einem enkelkind
präsident sie lenski bezeichnet butscher
als symbol für den völkermord russlands
an den ukrainern die welt soll das sehen
gleichzeitig wollen die ukraine genau
dokumentieren was hier passiert ist
kathrin guten abend ist hier in butter
heute klarer geworden was es für
hintergründe geben könnte für das was ja
wie ein massaker aussieht
also das was ich in butter gesehen habe
deutet ganz klar darauf hin dass hier
ein massaker stattgefunden hat die frage
ist natürlich wie das entstanden ist und
darüber beginnt die ukraine sich erst
langsam ein bild zu machen das ist ja
auch gar nicht einfach man muss es ja
aus verschiedenen sachen zusammengesetzt
sätzen aus augenzeugenberichten aus
untersuchungen der leichen ausgenommen
rekonstruktionen von dem was da passiert
ist was sich abzeichnet ist dass es sich
hier vermutlich um eine systematische
tötung von zivilisten gehandelt hat die
wirklich angeordnet war wovon man auch
ausgeht dass es bestimmte listen gab
dass man ganz gezielt säuberungen
vorgenommen hat gegen menschen die auf
russischen listen standen die als gegner
russlands bekannt waren und eine weitere
vermutung die sich immer weiter erhärtet
dass hier wohl auch russische söldner
gruppen zum einsatz gekommen sind
ist denn klar wieder zu leben das kann
man sich ja kaum vorstellen wie das
leben jetzt in einem ort wie butter
weitergehen soll
also im moment kann man dort eigentlich
nicht leben für uns war es als
journalisten schon ziemlich gefährlich
durch die straßen dort zu laufen dort
sind ja überall noch die spuren des
erschossenen autos die kaputten panzer
da sind giftstoffe da sind auch
teilweise splitter die gefährlich sind
also wir konnten auch nur gewisse wege
zurücklegen die armee uns genau gesagt
hat hier und hier könnt ihr euch bewegen
dann sind natürlich die meisten häuser
auch von elektrizität und gas
abgeschlossen viele bewohner sind
weggegangen können dort auch gar nicht
mehr leben ich denke das wird noch eine
ganz lange zeit dauern bis die menschen
dort nach butscher wieder zurückkehren
können katrin eigendorf live in kiel für
vielen dank
der us präsident fordert wegen butscher
heute einen kriegsverbrecherprozess
russland weist alle anschuldigungen
kategorisch zurück eine der
organisationen die das geschehene jetzt
untersucht und versucht möglichst genau
zu dokumentieren ist die
menschenrechtsorganisation human rights
watch deren deutschlanddirektor ist
jetzt bei uns wenzel michalski herr
michalsky sogenannten guten abend bei
michalsky erklären sie uns doch
vielleicht mal wie sie jetzt aktuell
vorgehen eher wir interviewen eine große
größtmögliche zahl von augenzeugen von
opfern möglicherweise auch von tätern
wir vergleichen diese aussagen auch mit
chats im internet oder auf den sozialen
medien wir untersuchen fotos und videos
die wir finden im internet
und da wo sich die fakten überschneiden
also da wo es ein match gibt die
aussagen von der einen seite unter
anderen seite identisch sind da wissen
wir da muss die wahrheit liegen und wenn
wir so etwas finden wenn wir so etwas
haben veröffentlichen wir das auch
wieviel matches haben sie denn bereits
jetzt gefunden oder anders gefragt gibt
es erste ergebnisse die darauf hindeuten
wer dafür verantwortlich ist für das was
wir da in butter sehen
wir haben das was wir jetzt gesehen
haben in butscher noch nicht untersucht
wer sind dabei wir haben leute die dort
hingehen wir haben aber ganz ähnliche
fälle auch in butter und in anderen
orten der umgebung auch in der umgebung
von kharkiv untersucht und zwar im
zeitraum von februar vom 27 februar bis
14 märz da sind schon solche greueltaten
passiert da haben wir zehn fälle
dokumentieren können wir haben uns wir
haben sehr viel mehr fälle untersucht
aber bei 10 fällen wussten wir hier
haben wir hieb und stichfeste beweise
dass wir das fest machen können und
veröffentlichen können wir können also
zeigen dass solche grausamkeiten schon
in der ganzen zeit der besatzung
stattfanden
wie sehr arbeiten sich jetzt gegen die
zeit also anders gefragt ist es wenn
jetzt gerade wertvolle beweise die sie
bräuchten in butter unbrauchbar
das ist zu befürchten wir haben ja
gesehen die massengräber
oftmals werden irgendwann mal diese
massengräber ausgehoben weil die
verwandten ein würdevolles ein würdiges
begräbnis sich wünschen und dabei werden
dann wertvolle beweise
zerstört deswegen bedrängen wir die
gemeinden die menschen die regierung die
massengräber zu schützen bis wirkliche
fachleute dort vor ort sind und die
massengräber fachgerecht untersuchen
können forensiker gerichtsmediziner um
die beweise zu sammeln mit denen dann
letztendlich die täter vor gericht
gestellt werden können jetzt
weißrussland alle anschuldigungen zurück
behauptet dass diesem video material sei
nicht zu trauen was sagen sie dazu
also diesen
dem kann man einfach nicht trauen also
man kann den russen ja überhaupt nichts
glauben man sieht ja schon anhand der
massiven und gezielten bombardierung
ziviler gebiete wohnblöcke kindergärten
krankenhäuser worauf die russen aus sind
nämlich auf einen krieg gegen die
zivilbevölkerung weil sie sonst an das
nicht schaffen sie wollen terror
veranstalten in der bei der
zivilbevölkerung um so das land zu
demoralisieren
deswegen sagen die natürlich jetzt auch
das waren wir nicht das waren die
ukraine wir können hier nicht erwarten
dass die russen selbst diese fälle
untersuchen und dann selber wertvolle
beweise finden und die täter aus ihren
eigenen reihen verfolgen das müssten sie
zwar da stehen sie in der pflicht aber
es wären sie bestimmt nicht tun herr
michalsky aus ihrer langen erfahrung in
der dokumentation von kriegsverbrechen
sie haben nicht erst in der ukraine
damit jetzt begonnen sehen sie bereits
indizien war dass ein befehl waren das
eventuell marodierende soldaten waren es
kämpfer aus tschetschenien über dieses
jahr zunehmend berichte gibt können sie
uns dazu etwas sagen bei diesem
konkreten fall in butter jetzt noch
nicht da müssen wir noch weiter
untersuchen allerdings der verdacht
liegt nahe weil wir wie gesagt schon
kriegsverbrechen systematischen
kriegsverbrechen auf anderen gebieten
gesehen haben die belagerung von städten
die gezielte bombardierungen von zielen
von von wohnblöcken die der einsatz von
international geächteten waffen wie
streubomben
deuten darauf hin dass ist dort eine
systematik gibt wenzel michalski
deutschland direktor von human rights
watch herzlich in der christ gespräch
heute abend danke auch
berichte über dutzende tote in den
straßen hunderte in massengräbern wenn
das grauen jede vorstellung übersteigt
dann drohen wir abzuschalten schon aus
selbstschutz umso wichtiger ist deshalb
zu zeigen dass hinter jedem einzelnen
opfer eine eigene geschichte steht ein
schicksal und trauernde die
zurückbleiben andreas stamm und jeremy
browne berichten
die hauptstraße von und nach kiew die
schlacht vorbei die russen weg in den
orten entlang bleiben gebrochene
menschen zurück sowie irina
kuschtschenko russische soldaten hätten
ihren sohn alexej auf offener straße
erschossen sie musste fliehen erklärt
sie bis vor kurzem hätte der feind in
seinem bett geschlafen in ihrem zuhause
gelebt vielleicht auch sein mörder
es tut so unglaublich weh
nun bin ich ganz allein mein sohn war 27
jahre jung er wollte doch nur am leben
bleiben
an seinem letzten tag wollte er zur
arbeit erzählt die 45-jährige in die
autowerkstatt 500 meter entfernt
mit einer schubkarre hat irina später
die leiche ihres sohnes zurück in den
garten geschafft ich habe eine decke
über sein grab gelegt als schutz vor den
hunden er liegt nicht in einem sarg ich
habe ihn in einem teppich eingewickelt
die russen kamen mit jeeps mit ihren
waffen sie haben ihn umgebracht und
sindh geflohen wie soll ich mit solchen
geisteskranken reden ich möchte sie und
ihre kinder tot in der erde sehen dass
es ihnen ergeht wie meinem sohn
in den trümmern findet irina noch ein
altes foto hier kleiner junge hier
alexej tod
ein leben ausgelöscht eine familie
zerstört
in einem moment kein schicksal in einem
krieg der seit fünf wochen an vielen
fronten in einem riesigen land tobt
[Musik]
wir reagieren auf all das diese frage
stellt sich ja schon länger sie wird mit
jedem neuen bild mit jedem neuen film
aus der ukraine drängen das spürt auch
die bundesregierung an deren haltung ist
heute einiges an kritik gibt auch aus
dem ausland die aber auch kante zeigen
will 40 russische diplomaten müssen
deutschland jetzt verlassen und die
deutsche gazprom tochterfirma steht
jetzt unter staatlicher deutscher
kontrolle david guetta hat
die bilder ausputzer verstören
schockieren und wirken nach heute auch
bei den berliner koalitionsparteien
wir sind alle
weiterhin in schockstarre
ob der bilder des grauens die ereignisse
in butter sind nur wenige stunden von
uns entfernt und sie dürfen nicht
ungesühnt bleiben das was wir erleben
ist dort eine form des
konzentrationslagers unter freiem himmel
doch was folgt auf das entsetzen das
überschreiten blutroter linien die
bundesregierung reagiert mit mehreren
vorstößen heute etwa mit der ausweisung
von 40 russischen diplomaten
mutmaßlichen agenten ihre arbeit
schreibt aussenministerin berbalk ist
eine bedrohung für diejenigen die bei
uns schutz suchen dies werden wir nicht
weiter dulden das haben wir den
botschafter russlands heute nachmittag
mitgeteilt zuvor hatte werburg der
ukraine neue auch andere waffen in
aussicht gestellt butter und mario pohl
zeigen dass es um leben und tod von
millionen von menschen in der ukraine
geht wir schauen uns daher jetzt auch
systeme an die wir bisher nicht
geliefert haben nur minuten später tritt
der wirtschaftsminister vor die kameras
um sein signal nach moskau zu senden die
bundesregierung tut das notwendige um
die versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
zu gewährleisten
dazu zählt auch dass wir energie
infrastrukturen in deutschland nicht
willkürlichen entscheidungen des tramp
des kremls aussetzen daher soll bei
gazprom germania der deutschen tochter
des russischen energiekonzerns
vorübergehend treuhänderisch die
bundesnetzagentur übernehmen gazprom
hatte vor wenigen tagen den deutschen
ableger verkauft die neuen
besitzverhältnisse aber blieben unklar
ist ein sehr scharfes schwert das da
gezogen wurde es erinnert ein bisschen
an eine enteignung das ist es aber noch
nicht sondern es ist eine
treuhänderische verwaltung dieses
unternehmens für sechs monate
natürlich muss man mit gegenreaktionen
rechnen aber wichtig ist jetzt erstmal
im sinne der versorgungssicherheit das
eben sichergestellt wird dass eben der
größte gasspeicher den es in deutschland
gibt das der auch tatsächlich gekühlt
wird gas soll also prinzipiell weiter
fließen trotz butscher scheut die
regierung ein sofortiges embargo setzt
weiter auf schrittweise unabhängigkeit
von russland sofortiger stopp hätte
immense folgen für deutschland nicht nur
für die industrie sondern auch für die
grundversorgung der bürgerinnen und
bürger und dann wir mit augenmaß
vorangehen und wir können nicht
jahrelang warten bis lieferungen aus
katar hier ankommen dann ist dieser
krieg längst vorbei das heißt wir müssen
schon in der lage sein schneller zu
handeln nord stream 1 wäre eine erste
möglichkeit wenn man hier stoppen würde
hätte man erst ein erstes klares signal
gesetzt auch von europäischen partnern
steigt nun der druck auf die
bundesregierung der polnische
ministerpräsident etwa klar da ist sind
die deutschen die sanktion am
entschieden ausbremst wir brauchen noch
mehr tempo und wir müssen noch schneller
entscheiden das ist alles nicht einfach
ist eine sehr sehr komplexe situation
aber es geht hier um das leben von
tausenden ich gehe so weit es geht um
das leben von millionen euro gerade wir
sind in verantwortung da nicht einfach
zuzuschauen derzeit wird europäisch ein
fünftes sanktionspaket abgestimmt ohne
energie embargo wenn es nach deutschland
geht nach butscher ist das entsetzen in
der regierung groß aber eben nicht alles
anders
beim thema corona heute eine nachricht
die grundlegende folgen haben wird auch
bei den quarantäne regeln in diesem land
gibt es so etwas wie eine zeitenwende
anna hat die details ab dem ersten mai
ist schluss mit der quarantäne und
isolations pflicht das haben die
gesundheitsministerinnen und minister
von bund und ländern entschieden
5 zu einem verfahren was im großen und
ganzen auf freiwilligkeit basiert und wo
es eben eine dringende empfehlung gibt
sich im falle einer ansteckung zu
isolieren und also sich danach frei zu
testen eine ausnahme sind infizierte
beschäftigte in krankenhäusern und
pflegeheimen für sie gilt weiterhin eine
isolationsschicht nach fünf tagen können
sie sich frei testen
die allgemeine impfpflicht ab 18 ist
vorerst vom tisch wenige tage vor der
abstimmung im bundestag haben die
bisherigen befürworter einen
kompromissvorschlag vorgelegt nämlich
eine impfpflicht ab 50 die später noch
durch einen bundestagsbeschluss auf
jüngere ausgewertet werden könnte
außerdem eine verpflichtende
impfberatung und ein impf register ob
der vorschlag eine mehrheit erreicht ist
allerdings fraglich mehr dazu später im
heute-journal update dann spricht nach
sein glückte mir mit dem virologen
professor schmidt chanasit
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
hat fehler in seiner russland politik
eingeräumt als beispiele nannte er sein
festhalten an der gaspipeline nord
stream 2 außerdem bezeichnete steinmeier
den versuch russland in eine gemeinsame
sicherheitsarchitektur einzubinden als
gescheitert steinmeier reagiert damit
auf die kritik an seiner politik als
ehemalige außenminister und chef des
kanzleramtes besonders scharf hatte ihn
der ukrainische botschafter wenig
angegriffen
ungarns ministerpräsident viktor orban
hat die parlamentswahl gewonnen und das
sogar deutlicher als erwartet seine
nationalkonservative fidesz partei kam
auf 53 prozent der stimmen das
oppositionsbündnis blieb mit 35 prozent
hinter den erwartungen zurück die
vize-präsidentin des eu-parlaments bali
kritisierte die wahl als unfair
russlands präsident putin gratulierte
regierungschef orban
und glückwünsche aus dem kreml gab es
auch für den serbischen präsidenten
alexander witsch dieser wurde im amt
bestätigt mit knapp 59 prozent der
stimmen auch seine rechtskonservative
fortschrittspartei bleibt stärkste kraft
im parlament hat aber ihre absolute
mehrheit eingebüßt
die bundesregierung will mehr tempo beim
ausbau der windenergie an land deshalb
sollen die genehmigungsverfahren und
bundesweit vereinfacht und damit
beschleunigt werden darauf haben sich
wirtschaftsminister herr beck und
umweltministerin lemke geeinigt zum
schutz von bedrohten vogelarten soll es
künftig einheitliche standards geben
außerdem dürfen windräder in zukunft
grundsätzlich auch in
landschaftsschutzgebieten gebaut werden
allerdings nur so lange bis zwei prozent
der bundes flächen für windenergie
genutzt werden das ist das erklärte ziel
ja es hätte diese welt nicht genug
herausforderungen zu meistern gerade
kommt noch eine hinzu die schon viel
länger da ist und die nicht weg gehen
wird ignorieren bringt also nichts im
gegenteil wir müssen sie meistern und
zwar nicht neben allen anderen sondern
vordringlich jetzt oder nie sagt der
weltklimarat heute wir sind längst im
roten bereich und mit dem was bislang
verabredet ist liege das 1,5 grad ziel
außer reichweite
es ist ein mahnender beinahe
verzweifelter appell wie christina
elsner berichtet
sie sind nicht land und nicht wasser die
moore ihre torfböden leisten einen
wichtigen beitrag zum klimaschutz denn
sie speichern doppelt so viel
klimaschädliches co2
die gleich große wälder so eine
klimabilanz braucht es dringender denn
je
der grund dafür seit jahrzehnten steigt
der weltweite treibhausgasausstoß
stetig an geht das so weiter wären die
folgen von mehr als vier grad
erderwärmung katastrophal um die im
pariser abkommen angestrebte obergrenze
von 1,5 grad erwärmung zu erreichen
braucht es eine drastische
emissionstrend wende ein co autor des
neuen sachstandsbericht es bringt es auf
den punkt die botschaft ist die emission
jetzt wirklich zu senken global und zwar
um die 45 prozent bis 2030 und das
erfordert viel politischen willen es
erfordert sehr viel
investition
investitionen die etwa in die
wiederherstellung von mooren fließen
sollen in deutschland wurden in der
vergangenheit 99 prozent der moorfläche
trockengelegt grund dafür der hunger
nach ackerflächen zudem ist die torf
erde ein begehrter rohstoff von
gärtnereien
natürlicher klimaschutz um das klimagas
co2 zu binden dafür will die
bundesregierung jetzt mehrere milliarden
euro zur verfügung stellen es braucht
aber noch weitere lösungen sagen die
experten des weltklimarates stichwort
technischer klimaschutz ja da finde ich
den bericht wirklich sehr hilfreich weil
er einfach noch mal sehr viel deutlicher
macht dass diese sogenannten co2
damit technologien die also das co2 der
atmosphäre direkt entziehen ein
notwendiger teil des klimaschutzes
co2 aus der luft holen und tief im boden
speichern
diese anlage in island kann es tausende
tonnen des klimagases will man hier mit
hightech in einen unterirdischen co2
dressur für die ewigkeit einschließen
der bericht man schließlich noch etwas
an wir brauchen darüber hinaus noch
andere speicherlösungen und wir brauchen
vor allem auch eine dekarbonisierung des
energiesystems gemeint damit ist der
weltweit schnellerer ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien die fakten sie
liegen auf dem tisch einem ernst
gemeinten klimaschutz stünde also nichts
mehr im weg
dem uno generalsekretär ist heute
angesichts des berichts der kragen
geplatzt zitat antonio guterres einige
regierungen und unternehmen sagen dass
eine und tun das andere
einfach ausgedrückt sie lügen wenig
diplomatisch aber sehr klar und
hier in der sendung jetzt nochmal hanna
es sind viele milliarden euro die der
comics skandal den deutschen staat
gekostet hat seit heute nun sitzt eine
schlüsselfigur in diesem steuerbetrug
auf der anklagebank der anwalt hanno
berger muss sich vor dem landgericht
bonn verantworten valerie haller an der
frankfurter börse was wird ihm genau
vorgeworfen
also das ist ja einer von vielen comics
fällen aber dieser ist besonders groß
berger wird schwere steuerhinterziehung
zwischen 2007 und 2013 vorgeworfen mit
einem gewaltigen schaden dem fiskus
sollen rund 280 millionen euro entgangen
sein berger bestreitet bis heute dass
die taten illegal gewesen sein mit hanno
berger muss sich nun eine schlüsselfigur
im comic skandal vor gericht
verantworten der ehemalige finanzbeamte
spätere wirtschaftsanwalt war fast zehn
jahre lang in die schweiz geflüchtet
wurde im februar aber ausgeliefert er
soll eine privatbank zu comics
geschäften bewogen und dabei geholfen
haben die dafür nötigen strukturen
einzurichten berger soll selbst kräftig
profitiert haben über 27 millionen euro
bei den sogenannten codex deals wurden
aktien schnell hin und hergeschoben bis
der fiskus nicht mehr wusste wem sie
eigentlich gehören die folge das
finanzamt erstattete die
kapitalertragsteuer gleich mehrfach
dabei wurde die fällige steuer nur
einmal bezahlt eine vielzahl weiterer
verfahren dürfte die gerichte in den
kommenden jahren beschäftigen comics
deals wurden in der finanz branche so
massiv betrieben dass dies der wohl
größte deutsche steuerfahnder wurde
anleger machten auf kosten des staates
kräftig rendite geld das an anderer
stelle nun fehlt vielen dank valerie
nach frankfurt
mehr als 30 jahre nach dem brandanschlag
auf eine asylbewerberunterkunft in
saarlouis mit einem toten und zwei
verletzten hat die polizei den
mutmaßlichen täter gefasst dem heute 50
jährigen tatverdächtigen wird mord
versuchter mord und brandstiftung mit
todesfolge vorgeworfen
er soll das feuer aus
rechtsextremistischen und rassistischen
motiven gelegt haben
in der nacht fanden in las vegas die
grammy awards statt großer gewinner des
abends war der jazz musiker john baptist
dem gleich fünf grammys verliehen wurden
als beste newcomerin ist die 19 jährige
olivia rodrigo ausgezeichnet worden
großes thema bei der gala war auch der
krieg in der ukraine in einer
videobotschaft rief präsident selensky
die musiker dazu auf sein land zu
unterstützen
ja und das war unsere welt an diesem
montag herzlichen dank für ihr interesse
wir wünschen ihnen jetzt noch einen
schönen abend
[Musik]
guten abend heute nacht kann auch etwas
schneeregen fallen hier in den östlichen
und südlichen mittelgebirgen und dann
wird es auch glatt sonst fällt häufig
regen morgen regnete es vor allen dingen
über der mitte deutschlands im nordosten
zeigt sich dagegen auch häufiger die
sonne bei sechs bis zwölf grad am
mittwoch gibt es vor allen dingen in
norddeutschland kräftigen regen am
donnerstag überquert uns ein sturmtief
und am freitag droht im südwesten
heftiger dauerregen
aber steht der wind im vordergrund und
dazu passt dass der heute
veröffentlichte letzte teil des
aktuellen weltklimaberichts noch mal
betont ohne massiven ausbau der
erneuerbaren verpassen wir das pariser
klimaziel in deutschland gibt es zurzeit
knapp 30.000 windkraftanlagen im norden
mehr als im süden im schnitt mit einer
leistung von 1,8 megawatt
moderne windräder schaffen dass
dreifacher sind effizienter und höher
weiter oben weht mehr wind zudem
gleichmäßiger als am boden die aktuell
größten windräder an land stehen in
brandenburg im nötigen abstand zur
bebauung kann so eine anlage mit 166
metern höhe rund
6800 drei personen haushalte mit strom
versorgen wir werden uns an ihren
anblick gewöhnen strommasten nehmen wir
auch kaum mehr wahr guten abend